this is a scene from the silent western
pinto ben
and here's what it looks like after it's
been restored
all that gunk in the before is chemical
decomposition which has destroyed an
estimated 75 percent of american silent
films but here is where they get saved
the george eastman museum where
archivists have rescued lost works of
filmmakers like stanley kubrick and
orson welles
one of its current projects is this a
western over a century old starring and
directed by william s hart one of the
biggest movie stars of the time and it's
particularly tricky because it's made of
nitrate the material is notorious for
being highly flammable and chemically
unstable which makes it prone to
decomposition
i'm sure you can start to
smell this i was wondering what that was
it smells like
nitrate that's starting to decompose my
colleagues feel it smells like a wet dog
when it gets very bad it's more like if
you took a dirty gym sock and put it in
a glass of sour milk
while pinto ben hasn't gotten to the
point of sour milk the clear film base
has started to discolor that's stage one
as we wind through it you could see how
it's becoming more and more brownish
yellow this was stage two where the
image has started to melt this is where
the emulsion in the film has broken down
the third stage the film starts to ooze
and bubble like a honey-like substance
up to that point parts of it can still
be salvaged and then stage four it
crystallizes into a hockey puck after
that it becomes a very fine brown powder
that process is irreversible and it can
happen surprisingly fast so archivists
like anthony have to identify
decomposing films and restore them to
new film stock before it's too late
in silent films like this they may start
looking around the title cards titles
usually were photographed and processed
more poorly than the images a lot of the
dcom can start from the titles and then
work its way through the rest of the
film then they'll start on physical
repairs
each of these splices marks a tear in
the film that an archivist fused back
together with liquid cement or damaged
frames that had to be replaced with
blank film some of these repairs were
done before the reel came into eastman's
possession another area that needs
mending these perforated edges if those
perforations get ripped off the tear can
spread inwards and begin to affect the
image
also those perforations when intact
allow the film to move safely through
the cleaner and scanner in the next
steps so in areas with extensive damage
the edge and the perfs are missing
completely anthony will use this special
tape to replace the missing perforations
by the end of this process the film will
look something like this
with all those white stripes marking
perforation repairs
once all those weakened areas have been
reinforced the film goes through this
ultrasonic cleaner to remove any dust or
dirt on the surface then the film is
finally digitized
it goes through the scanner which
captures each frame and turns it into a
digital file this process can take up to
48 hours for a two-hour film and the
team has to do this for every version of
the film they're going to use for the
reconstruction
eastman is reconstructing pinto ben from
six sources with each providing
different puzzle pieces of the film
two of the sources come from the 1917
reissue of the film under the title
horns and hooves the library of congress
preserved the nitrate for real one the
first half of the film and the negative
for real two the second half of the film
these sources have the best image
quality the shots look sharp and have
good contrast
but the library of congress nitrate is
the least complete element these frames
have some yellow ooze on the side which
marks the beginning of the decomposition
while these frames show it in its later
stages we cannot digitally restore this
because there is very little image
information for our software to look at
so we're going to want to use that for
as many scenes as we can but if frames
are missing or if the decomp and the
damage is so distracting and
irreconcilable we'll switch to the other
nitrate print that we have this nitrate
was sent over from france where pinto
ben was released as le pony de rio gym
some pieces were actually excised
throughout the years maybe because of
d-comp or damage we don't know to fill
in chunks that are still missing the
team will defer to one of three
lower-res prints of the film from a 1924
re-release
altogether these prints contain the most
information since they have the highest
number of frames intact but the image
quality here is probably the roughest
you can see the focus is a little bit
fuzzier
it's a little bit flatter the contrast
isn't as good
they can play with the contrast to help
correct for any obvious quality jumps
between frames and color grading will
help tie everything together and then
from all those different elements and
all those different frames we assemble
as completed version as possible once a
timeline of all the best shots has been
created digital restoration begins the
first thing to correct is this shaky
movement you see between frames often
it's the result of film shrinking over
time shrunken film doesn't go through
the scanner as well so you can end up
with an unstable image we know in like
analog film there's a little bit of a
slight vibration in the film image but
if it were to regularly kind of
distractingly move up and down we would
try and eliminate that to a degree the
thing that this element suffers from is
mostly scratching software helps detect
these but it's not a perfect solution in
this film there's a lot of wallpaper and
a lot of vertical lines that resemble
these types of scratches so i put in a
scratch that's very thick it's going to
say hey i'm this line on the wallpaper
right i should be removing that he can
use the same kind of programmed filters
to help detect dark dirt light dust or
other errant artifacts like the stray
eyelash or hair that may have become
embedded into the print so that's just a
piece of parent dirt that fell you know
onto the film at some point other
artifacts might be captured in the image
itself for example if there was dirt on
the printer or a camera negative when
the film was printed however many years
ago you tend to find the most dirt and
dust at the ends of the film those would
be exposed to the elements more just
sitting in a can would be their heads
out or tails out that would accumulate
dust when you're putting it in the can
taking it out
in general the more popular a film was
and the more times it was shown in
theaters the more likely it is to have
suffered extensive wear and tear from
scratches and thumb prints to spots like
this where the emulsions rubbed off a
common effect of repeated projection
the last step in the process color
grading here the team has the scanned
frames of pinto ben up on the screen and
the nitrate film out on the inspection
table the goal is to make the colors on
that screen match those in the physical
reference as closely as possible this
takes a lot of precision and teamwork
warmer colder i would say warmer but i
feel like we've lost some of the
saturation it's a very deep vivid almost
radioactive yellow
they have to be very gentle with a print
like this as they go through and inspect
the color in each scene as you can see
the film is kind of bending in one
direction as well as these edges here
are kind of buckling out a little bit
those are all signs of warpage and
physical deterioration of the film stock
if that gets any worse this element
might not be able to be scanned in the
future and so when we inspect it we move
through it very slowly
because the last thing we want to do is
to introduce more damage to the film
print
at the end of the process the film looks
like this pretty close to how it was
originally seen by audiences back in
1915
and that's the goal
we're trying to present the film as an
artifact and an art form the way it was
originally presented this whole process
can take up to two years which means
many movies are deteriorating faster
than archives can preserve them
if we have a unique print where we know
that this is the last surviving element
of a film and we notice that it's
starting to decompose that will go to
the top of our preservation priority
list pinto ben is one of nine william s
hart films eastman is restoring and one
of thousands of movies the museums
helped rescue from being lost forever
[Music]
you